hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a retro
breakdown of Game of Thrones the 2011
pilot season 1 episode 1 winter is
coming yeah this is a new thing we're
trying we love breaking down Game of
Thrones and many of you have requested
that we go back and break down classic
episodes as we wait for the final season
to arrive in 2019 so we're giving it a
shot maybe we'll do every episode and
seasons 1 through 5 to catch us up to
where I breakdown started in season 6
well maybe people just do select
memorable episodes we're a busy Channel
we cover a lot of stuff so it'll depend
on what we have time for honestly but
the plan here is to go deep into the
details you missed from these earlier
episodes and to point out all the
interesting connections in the way that
they set up these future events so let's
get started with the prologue scene in
which the three brothers of the Nights
Watch trekked north of the wall one
thing that struck me while we watching
the scene was the tone that it sets as
the introduction of a series unlike
openings to other fantasy adaptations
like the Lord of the Rings or The
Chronicles of Narnia or even the opening
scenes to pass HBO period series like
Deadwood or Rome the prologue of Game of
Thrones is pure horror honestly it's one
of the most frightening sequences in the
entire series this pilot is going out of
its way to establish Game of Thrones as
very different from any other fantasy
series you may have seen before and a
big reason for this horror is the music
and sound editing so let's discuss all
these subtle audio techniques used here
in our segment do that okay first I
think it's interesting that the first
distinct sound we hear in Game of
Thrones before any actual words are said
is this
you're that that was a howl yes a wolf
howl is kind of a classic horror sound
effect but if we assume this is a dire
wolf this is also kind of a signal that
the mythical beasts that once never came
this far south are now breaking those
rules another subtle reminder that
winter is coming
we should also obviously talk about the
music here composer Ramin Djawadi fills
our ears with the iconic creepy white
Walker theme
jadi said that he created this by using
glass bowls
he said that glass produces an eerie
cold sound the sound ice would make if
it could produce a tone now it's also
interesting to re-watch this pilot
notice the little ways that sets of
details that become important later in
the series for example notice the
pattern in these severed body parts form
in the snow a bisected circle this
symbol shows up way later in the series
in the most recent season in the cave
paintings John discovers on Dragonstone
we still don't know exactly what they
mean I speculated they could be the
children of the forest symbol for the
first men a symbol that the White
Walkers would have adopted since they
were created by the children they're
actually a lot of seemingly throwaway
details in this episode which now having
watched this series actually proved to
have a deeper significance so let's
break them all down in this segment in
hindsight okay when Ned Stark executes
swill for deserting the wall he educates
bran with some important fatherly wisdom
the man who passes the sentence should
swing the sword now of course those
words became hugely influential on Rob
and John and later seasons but there's
actually another line that gets
overlooked that Ned speaks to bran that
I found interesting and sees what he
sees so this first episode establishes
bran as a witness in a seer he perceives
these violent shocking unbelievable
things while he remains frozen unable to
look away this foreshadows his future
role as the three-eyed Raven a figure
who witnesses these unbelievable visions
while he himself remains paralyzed and
with this line Ned explains to brand
that what others may perceive as madness
is certainty to the madman now speaking
of foresight noticed this detail of
brand spotting the Kings arrival from
this bird's-eye view at the top of the
tower I still the King think about it
this line kind of echoes the three-eyed
Raven bran seeing the arrival of a
future king and his masses next up this
has been pointed out before but the dead
stag in the direwolf forum another key
symbolic image the sigils of the house
Baratheon and Stark having gored each
other for shadows the conflict between
Robert and Ned later this season and the
fact that both of these men won't make
it out of this season alive also notice
are these opening scenes foreshadow
Arya's role in the show before she says
any lines of dialogue she shows up brand
pie bull's eye in the
target and then dons a helmet Aria is
already defying the traditional gender
roles and that androgyny will play a
bigger role in her future escape from
King's Landing actually masquerades as a
boy and her training with the faceless
men also interesting is the look of
fascination Aria gives another character
who hides his face under a helmet the
hound the intercutting shots between
these characters hints at the
relationship they'll have later in the
series then something really cool
happens when King Robert greets the
stark family notice how each of the
characters he physically touches later
died premature deaths he hugs Ned and
Catelyn he tussles richens hair and he
shakes Rob's hand meanwhile everyone
whom he doesn't touch gets spared from
this doom Kings touch of death also
notice the words Robert says to Arya the
whole name is he says nothing further I
think this is a wink at arias future
identity as a girl who has no name then
when Robert requests to pay his respects
to Lyanna Stark Cersei complains surely
the Dead Can Wait seriously maybe the
only major character on Game of Thrones
who is not at all concerned with the
dead she's not superstitious or
irreverent she only cares about living
threats actually the Dead Can Wait is
pretty much the gist of her recent
decision to back out of helping John and
Danny fight the army of the dead it's
also interesting how strongly this pilot
episode establishes Lyanna stark as this
ghost figure that haunts all of these
characters now of course the truth about
Liana became a major game changer in
recent seasons and I like out right away
they teased this reveal with the
dialogue she belongs with me in my
dreams like
it's done you grace tell Gary ins are
gone so Ned says it's done he wants
Robert to move on from his obsession
with the Targaryen the reason is he
knows Liana secretly loved Rhaegar with
Jon being the proof of that
the true heir to the Iron Throne and by
saying not all of them
Roberts technically referring to Viserys
and Dany but this paranoia applies to an
even greater threat to his rule right
under his nose now moving on I like this
little costuming detail with viserys and
danerys the three-headed dragon pin now
Dany later wears this in season 7 when
she finally returns to Dragonstone
despite fearing and hating her brother
she wanted to reconnect with her family
during that sacred homecoming by using
this wardrobe it's also interesting that
we see Danny immerse herself in this
scalding hot bath undisturbed by the
heat now the chapter in the book goes
more into Danny's strange tolerance for
extreme heat but without saying anything
in this scene the pilot already gives us
this hint at Danny's future as the
unburnt mother of dragons and then
notice how Danny is listening in when
Illyrio makes these promises to
Missouri's people drink secret toasts to
your health
Danny remembers these BS assurances from
an advisor later with Varys in season 7
they cry out for that true queen they
drink secret toasts to my health now
back in Winterfell this moment between
John and his uncle Benjen is interesting
retrospect it seems less surprising that
John was the one to survive this long
while the rest of his family is inside
getting drunk
he's outside working on his sword
fighting skills and benjin asking is it
dead yet as he hacks away at the dummy
he almost feels like a nod to John's
future swinging hopelessly at undead
whites and then notice this line from
John lady stark thought it might insult
the royal family to see two busted in
limits now in the book John is allowed
to join the feast inside just not at the
head table with the family but here they
change it to give another example of
Caitlyn's contempt for John along with
that look that she gave him earlier and
John telling bran your mother is
watching and yeah I also appreciate the
irony of the Starks thinking the
Lannisters would be insulted by having a
bastard in their midst guys they had
three of them now this episode has to
introduce a ton of characters and of all
of them the most fleshed out and
entertaining to watch is Tyrion in this
scene with John he gives us
is to me one of the best lines of the
series quoted directly from george RR
martin never forget what you are the
rest of the world will not buy at it
like armor and it can never be used to
hedge now tyrion embracing his stature
as a Dorf like Armour becomes a source
of strength to his character this line
reverberates throughout some of Tyrians
finest moments I'm guilty of being a
jewel meanwhile at the feast notice this
interaction between Cersei and Sansa and
happy budget that uncertain book sense
it gives her mother perfectly conveys
just how naive and innocent Sansa still
is and notice how Cersei asks that
question kind of threatening Lee
foreshadowing how the Queen will use
Sansa's womanhood to terrorize her in
future seasons and speaking of threats
there's this less discreet war of words
between Ned and Jaime I don't function
to reduce this was a bunch of men for
reals now obviously this is setting up
the combat the two of them will have
later this season Jaime's final line in
this episode as he shows bran half the
window is such a great middle finger to
fans
I forgot how fast and almost comedic
this moment feels things I do for love
as much as we hate Jaime here the things
I did for love becomes his character's
philosophy throughout the series he
throws himself in a danger and each time
love is the reason for it love for
Cersei for his children for Tyrion for
Brienne killing the Mad King was about
love and compassion for thousands of
innocents and the fact that he does all
of these things for love is what will
eventually help Jaime redeem his actions
and many of the viewers eyes one of my
favorite shots this episode is the one
with Ned deciding whether to take the
job as hand of the king and notice how
Catelyn and maester Luwin are framed as
the angel and devil on his shoulders
each whispering their case in his ear
actually a parallel version of the shot
comes back later in the series with
Stannis as the decision maker and Davos
and Melisandre as the competing
influences on his shoulders now catlins
opinion in this scene was changed from
the books what how dare they let's
actually discuss these differences and
why they were made and how they affect
the show in our segment well in the
books okay so in book 1 a game of
Thrones it was Catelyn not maester Luwin
who urged Ned to go to King's Landing to
uncover the
behind John Aaron's murder and to
protect Robert but he or she fears for
her husband's safety and begs him to
stay out of it and stay with her in
Winterfell Benioff and Weiss adapted
this to soften Catelyn and to warm her
in Ned's marriage so that we root for
these characters more and thus heighten
shock for when that beloved husband
loses his head at the end of the season
now another more controversial change in
the books happened with Daenerys this
episode there's actually two moments
early on when Viserys threatens her he
undresses her and warrants or not to
wake the dragon well in the books
Viserys also pinches her breast heart
and twists show left it out but then at
the end of the episode after their
wedding called Drogo and dresses her
again repeating the word know which is
the only word he knows in the common
tongue and this continues as Daenerys
trembles in fear and at no point
indicates that she wants this well in
the books the scene ends with Daenerys
consenting to sex with Drogo with Drogo
asking No and Dany knowing it was a
question that time and Dany teaching him
a new word yes now I'll admit I liked
the book version a lot better it's her
first step from being a victim to taking
more control of her story and the
showrunners did take some heat for
changing it but one could argue it does
fit in better within the theme of the
episode winter is coming
like if Danny began this episode as a
victim of sexual abuse by her brother
and then ended it with his victory of
her turning the tables on Drogo that
would kind of conflict with the idea of
all these characters plights becoming
worse instead we get to see Danny
gradually transition to more of her
conquer her self as this season goes on
I'm not defending the change of the
books I can just see why this episode
wanted to leave all their main
characters in these awful situations now
speaking of Khal Drogo one little detail
that I liked from him was this Dothraki
phrase he says while watching his men
fight at his wedding this is actually a
chant from the traditional Maori haka
war dance which Jason Momoa used during
his audition and he says it got him the
role and then later language consulted
David J Peterson who created the spoken
languages of Dothraki and Valyrian for
Game of Thrones retro actively worked in
eat a waka into the Dothraki language so
that it translates to testier might
basically he made it so that Khal Drogo
is the guy watching the fights in mortal
combat now the director of this episode
was Tim van
he directed the pilot and Episode two
but no other episodes on the show HBO
brought him in after he directed a ton
of episodes of The Sopranos the wire and
Boardwalk Empire then Patton is
considered a master of visuals and
pacing and one thing he does really well
is frame specific shots so that a
character is linked with the instrument
of their death in one of my favorite
shots in Boardwalk Empire Van Patten
pointed the camera downward as mr.
Harrow lowered his rifle seemingly
disarming himself but then he angles the
rifle back upward directly up into the
lens of the camera the point of view of
the other guy in the standoff the camera
angle lines up the death blow and then
Van Patten does a similar thing in the
pilot a game of Thrones early on when
the deserter is brought to the chopping
block he's framed within the concave
divot of that block with the blood of
past condemned men still staining the
wood the camera angle lines up the death
blow and then now I should say that Tim
Van Patten was not the original director
on the Game of Thrones pilot there was
an entirely different unaired version by
another director which according to
Benioff and Weiss was so bad that they
had to reshoot 90% of it it's actually
pretty interesting to examine what was
changed and why so let's run through
these adjustments okay starting with
this opening sequence notice these shots
of the Nights Watch brothers leaving
Castle black the original pilot simply
began with them finding the dead
wildlings in the haunted forest and in
that version the wildlings were just
kind of piled up not arranged in this
creepy pattern also the White Walkers
were originally more visible with the
script describing their frozen skin and
how they spoke to each other in a weird
language course the final version left
the White Walkers shrouded in darkness
we don't really get a good look at them
until the end of season 2 The effect of
this is that the White Walkers are left
as a more mysterious threat with their
carnage resembling something more like a
psychotic serial killer would do the
original pilot also had a different
opening credits sequence that version
showed an old man writing a message and
strapping it to a raven with the Ravens
soaring over the continent of Westeros
and landing on the Iron Throne actually
this shot of the raven landing at
Winterfell with the news of Jon Aaron's
death might be a nod to that title
sequence now one of the biggest changes
to the pilot was the addition of the
stark family dynamic Catelyn was recast
from Jennifer Ehle - Michelle Fairley
and the archery scene the hair brushing
scene the shot of Ned and Captain
bed together and the scene with the boys
getting their hair cut were all added to
contextualize the Starks as a family
unit bene huffin Weis later lamented
that the haircutting scene was in their
opinion the most cringeworthy scene in
the entire series all the actors in the
scene reportedly tried to out macho each
other by doing a bunch of sit-ups and
then they held their breath to flex
their abs during the scene wouldnt think
about the scene isn't really that
necessary they're just getting their
hair cut
they also reassigned the line our way is
the old way from Ned to brand this way
bran is characterized as a kid who has
already begun to understand his father's
wisdom by the time his father has to
immediately leave him next notice the
first words that we hear Jaime speak to
his sister in the pilot that's your
brother I feel it's my duty to warn you
you worry too much a huge problem with
the original pilot was that apparently
viewers didn't understand that Jaime and
Cersei were brother and sister and that
their affair was incestuous so this
whole conversation between Cersei and
Jaime was added in the second pilot
originally Cersei was talking to pycelle
here to clarify this relationship
further the showrunners also added this
random voiceover dialogue between Sansa
and Arya that's Jaime Lannister pleased
to impress you please shut up
notice we never see the actresses say
these lines that's because they dubbed
it over in post-production also with
that Jon Arryn funeral scene the actor
plain Jon Arryn is John standing a
well-known British actor he only makes a
cameo as a corpse in this version but
originally the old pilot showed his
death a scene that standing called
lunatic Jon Arryn was going to crawl out
of bed across the room and reach for ink
to write something but then he would
spill the ink all over himself and
Cersei would come in the room and stomp
on his hand the original pilot also
contained a flashback to the death of
Ned's brother Brandon stark and a cameo
by george RR martin as a pentose a
nobleman at Danny's wedding with a weird
hat actually think this is a character
that he played originally before it was
reshot and recast by the way they did
this mostly to recast Daenerys from
Tamzin merchant to Emilia Clarke okay
let's close out by talking about the
deeper meaning of this episode so the
episode is titled winter is coming the
stark family words but also a primary
thematic promise of the series and a
marketing slogan used over and over
throughout the show's run but what does
it really mean here when you think about
it the phrase winter is coming is
paradoxical on Game of Thrones
the opening sequence takes place in a
setting where winter has clearly arrived
it's not coming it's here and season
after season as winter descends over
Westeros still winter is coming are the
words that's because for the Starks as
cold and as dark as things currently
seem something colder and darker is
always coming there's always a way for
your circumstances to get even worse so
prepare no character this episode
improves their situation the stark
family gets split up as Ned heads into a
deadly political game he's not prepared
for John is left out in the cold brand
becomes crippled Searcy and Jamie's
secret affair becomes compromised Dany
is forced into a marriage with the
foreign stranger and none of these
characters began the episode with
particularly fortunate days either
things were already pretty bleak a white
Walker attack an execution a dead hand
of the king a dead dire wolf orphans and
exiles can embed yet still on top of all
this winter is coming and as we'll see
over the coming episodes and the coming
seasons Game of Thrones will find new
and shocking ways to deliver on that
promise where even when characters take
one step forward they take two steps
back worsening and worsening their
situations
no one ever succeeds they merely survive
and at a great cost because on Game of
Thrones winter just keeps coming
which of these fallen characters do you
miss the most now as much as I love Sean
Bean on this show Ned Stark was I think
more powerful to the series in his death
meanwhile Michelle Fairley's Catelyn
Stark and mark Addie's Robert Baratheon
were huge reasons I think that first
season worked and I don't know if the
show ever really recovered from their
losses and which character do you think
changed the most from the series
premiere to the season 7 finale now of
course Jamie Lant okay you know what
it's just brand right
you went from a boy to a tree weigh in
in the comments below and also let us
know what kind of Game of Thrones video
you want to see next like more of these
retro breakdowns like this do you want
me to continue with season 1 episode 2
or jump around to more game-changing
episodes like their lore or Blackwater
red wedding mountain versus the Viper
hardhome as I said we cover a lot of
stuff I can't guarantee that we'll cover
all this so it'll really depend on what
videos you guys want to watch and by the
way if you want to have it even bigger
say in what kind of videos we make here
you can join our team by contributing to
us on patreon big thanks to all of our
current
especially Wilhelmina Edison you can
also help us want to make more of these
types of videos by sharing it and liking
it and subscribing to new rock stars you
can hit me up on Twitter at EA Vossler
for all the new rock stars at new rock
stars for updates on her videos alright
thanks for watching bye